and we have breaking sports news here
first at four o'clock the golden knights
naming a brand new head coach thanks for
joining us i'm denise feldas and i'm
brian loftis we want to get right over
to sports director chris matthews live
in studio with what is really chris a
big announcement yeah thank you brian
denise the golden knights have hired
their third head coach in six years one
month after letting peter deboer go the
knights within the last 60 minutes
signed bruce cassidy as head coach of
the vegas franchise it's signed and
sealed the 57 year old was recently
fired by the boston bruins where he
coached for six years and two years
prior to that with the washington
capitals so he's got some history with
knight's president of hockey operations
george mcphee they were together in
washington but cassidy only lasted two
years with the caps in boston he was
there six years won 62 percent of his
games and led the bruins to the stanley
cup final in 2019 but lost to alex
petrangelo in the st louis blues he
reportedly works well with veterans and
that's got to be good news for knights
who are just full of older players big
shock is when he was let go by the
bruins our cbs affiliate caught up with
cassidy in boston
for anybody that's a father that
you know you have to talk to your
children about
hey you know uh this is what's going to
happen you know listen i don't have a
crystal ball i don't know where we're
going to be next we know we're we're
fine we're you know like everyone's
healthy
yes like he says they'll be fine knights
recently making the announcement on
social media were waiting for a press
conference with cassidy most likely
tomorrow one thing about the nhl over
the other north american major sports
coaches don't last very long so to see
cassidy in boston for six years as head
coach was pretty impressive the average
tenure of an nhl coach is 2.4 years guys
back over to you that is not long